moscou la forteresse des barrages
partout les commerces fermés et cette
fois il n'y a pas que des policiers
l'armée est venue en renfort pour
protéger le siège des services secrets
là où alex et navales menées avec audace
heureusement convoqué les manifestants
ils font tout pour qu'on rentre à la
maison nous chassent pas perdre et on
reste parce qu'on en peut plus de cette
femme
rapidement ils se sont appropriés des
intersections entière avant d'être
repoussé dès qu'on perçoit qu'il ya une
menace de manifestations et bien on
arrête les jeunes surtout parce que
c'est surtout ceux qui ont aujourd'hui
donc ce kit est clair on a en un
mouvement de dispersion dispersé mais
tenace et partout nous avons suivi des
centaines de manifestants cette fois
jusqu'à la prison ou à l'excès navale
net ans ferme
wagué traînée au sol parfois frappé la
plupart ont été arrêtés
gourgeon c'est horrible géant de l'aude
autorités de cette femme comment
font-elles pour regarder leurs propres
enfants dans les visibles manquiez ces
jeunes attendent que camions se libère
pour être amenés au poste de aussi qu
elle a peur mais suit les policiers
d'autres arrestations sont troublantes
et difficile même à regarder cet homme
que la police a maîtrisé à coups de
pistolet électrique a perdu connaissance
sur les onze fuseaux horaires du pays
d'autres scènes de violence mais de
solidarité et courage aussi des milliers
d'arrestations des blessés de semaine en
semaine
le prix à payer pour s'opposer au régime
de vladimir poutine semble de plus en
plus élevé ici tamara alter escaut
radio-canada moscou